mi piace un sacco questo colore
ciao a tutti l'italia è oggi a
grandissima richiesta alexa contro
rossini comunque l'altro video in cui
alessia controllava il nostro slime ha
raggiunto i 10 mila mi piace qui come
vedremo para netta contro stiri s anche
questo video raggiunge i 10 mila mi
piace faremo saletta contro google
lasciate un bel mi piace questo video
cioè come funziona lesta e tiri
sceglieranno i nostri ingredienti ora
dovremmo fare carta forbice spazio per
vedere a chi capita l'ex ea chi capita
seeley esperto il capital ex perché di
una serie cattivissima resina e
cattivissima che non capisce anche oltre
alla genetica per cattiva famiglia
sparita come sempre alla fine del video
vi metterò questo invece dovrete votare
se vinco io se vince è vitale in volta
alla bellezza dello stress nei suoni mr
mi raccomando votate per lo slide non
per la persona perché quasi sempre
anche se lo tengo in ballo è quello di
via san vitale è bottiglione di mostarda
scelto più giallo portarlo prende di
cogorno che televisori e iniziamo subito
e ora dobbiamo vedere ora ti fa più da
serie a chi capita l'ex inizia prima la
facciamo noi due
ok e poi chi inizia se vince prende a
rezza se perde perde siri carta fuori
c'è stato
no quindi inizio io sasso carta forbice
ok giochiamo 321 forbice bici così male
che non comporterà bene sarebbe c'è
sempre priora over con le colleghe
motilità carte pressato carta poi
intanto oggi sono sfortunatissimo a
letta di un colore a caso che a crema
crema avremo quindi quella che si
avvicina più a color crema
per me invece ma sappiamo che a destra v
3 per a bere non fa invece si deve
chiedere un numero a caso tra 12345
traumi ma non a caso tra 1 e 5 da due 3
4 3 ma porterò impegnate la fede
coraggio né da che pigmento ts il valore
infatti c'è il marrone il grigio quindi
vedremo che mettiamo la mia con la
gialla a testa in questo primo tempo
siamo stati tutti e due fortunati ma
parcheggio imprese il viola bellissimo
the polyphonic allora parlare e 93 tutto
il giorno di latera marrone veramente il
grande bayliss diretto tra l'altro è uno
dei colori preferiti della serie b
perché in tantissimi a sanchez e poi
stai pure di ingannarlo perché c'è alle
paillettes lunghe le liti rinuncia i
glitter miste che quasi finita questa
cosa
eccolo qua finora si mostra come il mio
viola è più bello del tuo gioco con
centro
certo se guardate bene vedremo in base
alla tv che sembra un blu notte ma viola
peccato che questa col super piccola
quindi nonna non ce n'è stato fatto per
galaxy però lo metterei quanto
ingredienti tra cui fabio mi piace
secondo round per il secondo round ci
sono tutti i pigmenti e ci sono i miei
valori
questo ma anche questo proposito come no
c'è questo e questo da parte quando è
andrebbe bene se ho parlato mi hanno
parlato ma anche queste celeste no no è
questo bronzo non lo so si forse bronzo
quello che si sta meglio con il giallo
che è un marrone
quindi vediamo di inizia carta politica
di un colore a caso russo di iniziano
rosso venezia stavolta va letta che
avete avvicinata sarà iniziano a mano
aperta
cosa chiedere a siri deve darmi un
colore ottici che non funziona secondo
me non lo dice però prova si divincolava
caso tv un numero da 1 a 10
bianco perlato c'entra niente
sì proprio la fortuna non si è capaci a
fare uno skill quali sono stata molto
fortunata con il rosso veneziano anche
se sono molto curioso di vedere come
diventa adesso mi piace un sacco questo
colore
ma diventerà tutto metallizzato certo
giallorosso così diventerà parare
no non lo vedi che sta diventato il
miglior muratore sta diventando un
bellissimo arancione metelli modesta in
corso di tutta questa polvere di stelle
polvere di stelle giornata il bellissimo
ranger metallizzato per sé non aver mai
fatto uno slam arancione metallizzato
con i glitter anche quindi speriamo di
continuare a essere fortunata con i
colori e con gli ingredienti minore
bellissimo mi piace tantissimo è un po
incasinato qua con la polvere ma una
volta attivato raffiche di muoviamo un
po il suo cast come diventa come il
bianco e nero questo bianco parlato
almeno gli darà qualche riflesso
mettendo di fatto anzi forse ci sta a me
perché può fare che con le stelle le
stelle nel galaxy galassia non ha messo
poco vediamo un 1 a 0
bianco bianco gridano risultato grigio
porto 0
per l'altro ma quando mi sembra lavando
ha rovinato si tutti fortunatamente una
gara gazebi giorno bellissimo
c'era il mio più bello applicato
decisamente più bello al mio terzo round
per il terzo round
abbiamo le palline tutto è un fitto roma
volta la necessità
poi ci sono le fishburne che non le
voglio molti colori
non mi piacciono che ne giusta
andrebbero benissimo mi piacerebbero
molto bene perché farebbero di affetto
galaxy
allora in questo caso quando all extra
sceglierà un colore siccome si sono sia
le palline che il flex di quel colore
per esempio sceglie blu oceano poi le
possa scegliere tra uno e due così
vediamo se se di flex o le palline ok
vediamo utilizza carta fuori stato
scacciato rizzato no giusto del pianeta
la provinciale di mio colore a caso mi
dispiace non lo so di un colore a caso
si offre valenza dimmi un colore adesso
dimmi colore a caso brutta gen dogen
vabbè comunque blu male anche se non c'è
il gran capo di niente blu con il mio
arancione e giallo forse si sta bene lo
sa
1 2 ora che dovrà far scegliere tra uno
e due quindi o questo o questo alexa
dimmi un numero a caso tra 1 e 2 27 mar
come piazza se i flames io preferivo la
pallina o vediamo a che cosa sei quindi
essere gli devo dire i numeri 2 4 6 8 10
troviamo berna cenno 8 il 9 e il 10 che
mi fanno paura
[Risate]
e i si ri del mio numero tra 1 e 10
[Musica]
quello che non volevi lametino italiani
alla neve pista tra l'altro questo è
quella neve finta un po strana quella
già attivata
non vedo l'ora di vedere come reggerà il
tuo gara devo scappare
[Musica]
no mi sono detto che dovevo feat
no verde conca proclamato tutto addosso
tech bronzo venire o la mamma mia
allora mettiamola deve fitta di natale
tutto il braccio di tale disastro di
pista vari problemi avere fatto la rete
o passo con il contrario
mettiamo ora i glitter blu che non ci
sarà niente con questo renzo forse
stanno creato sembra un po la stessa
consistenza di quella neve cosa sono che
sicuro vediamo come diventa che non
c'entra molto
un po è dilettato il tuo famoso ma
vediamo il tuo come diventano il mio può
essere marte invece può essere marcio
allora vediamo la busta qua
semidistrutta mettiamo un po ma io direi
basta così si scopre fatto che è
accumulato rimane adesso che è stato
calcolato tutto ti amo anche questo che
vi è caduto un po come dire che per
cauto corde impara verso al 28 ma non si
fa per me mettiamola corpo è così
mettiamo tutti questi sono caduti per
terra
qua sul tavolo e perché trasparente
l'ultimo round questi qua
vediamo chi mi siano facciamoli
chiediamo sempre il colore oppure il
numero perché ci torno
tanti colori tante forme e colori civile
stellina tutte le stelline l'ho già
detto carta con stato prima che vengono
fatte da dare a quanti sono a 2 44 sono
tantissimi vediamo la fir impazzisce e
siri di mio numero tra 144 39 quindi
quindi 44 43 42 41 43 38
i cuoricini verdi dimostrano che finora
non era capitato il verde a nessuno dei
due è stata italiana fine verdi poi
facciamo vedere anche da vicino vicino
all ex di un colore a caso ho dei dubbi
ma passano ha capito che siete i gusti
difficili
alexa dimmi un colore a caso incarnato
prugne linkato con lui milioni propugna
serve un viola carnato puglia però dico
anche color carne quindi forse
questo incarna tremila secondo ma questo
questo questo incarnato prugna del il no
il cavallo brugna è incarnato nella
dieta questo viola sono state fortunate
nuovamente alexandra brava letta alexa
tista conti stacco la connessione è
purtroppo non trovo la risposta alla
domanda che da mettere le mie stelline
color internet prugne che ben sono
bellissime
altra vinto i correttivi verdi miliardi
verranno più belli ma dimostra
giovanissimo ha peccato che si nascondo
però non vedo l'ora di vedere come
attivo questi qua perché ha un colore
più per far timbrato la bruttura è tutto
metallizzato bellissimo militano
bereguardo indietro avete i cuori
galactic il mio galaxy a dei cuori
stellari o delle stelle a forma di cuore
noi anzi bellissimo e ci stanno bene
guarda sembrano tanti piccoli sembrano
dei piccoli fiorellini nemmeno la
galassia io venga massi e fiorito
vedremo per entrarvi bella è che la
siria nel mio
vedremo ok ora andiamo ad attivarli e
poi fa in tre tributare qual è il più
bello se tu perdi 3 2 1 st
ecco coesione lime e super arancione è
arancione metallizzato a me lo faccio
vedere un po meglio vedete a tutte le
sfumature metallizzate e rimasto molto
morbido e si sente un po scricchiolare
dei glitter pentite non sono tantissimi
però un pochino assistente
guardate un po il colore è una sorta di
era arancione arancione bronzo sentiamo
dei suoni
ecco è piccolino
ed ecco qua quindi questo è il mio amore
a quello di evitare
ed ecco il mio il colore fa lago di
questo sliven cervello portare con tutti
i cuoricini verdi che stanno benissimo
dire che i polsini verdi 3 ebbene sì
contro la si sta molto perbene in lilla
molto chiaro sì c'è una stanza che abbia
attivato tanto riesce comunque ad essere
abbastanza elastico e adesso facciamo
una presentazione allo swing presentato
così estate che bollino soprano rosa
accade sempre super carilo si fa un po
di rumori fanno tanti elemento bianco lo
ha fatto un pochino più chiaro che si
vedono tutti si è segnato qua lavanda io
chiamerei lo slime lavanda e poi ci sono
tutti questi brillantini rotondi e i
cuoricini verde che sono fantastici né
perché vi aspetto è carino per come sarà
di consistenza
vediamo se poi dritto e futuri tonetto
che va troppo a questo colore bello però
da e alla fine se riuscisse parlare di
futuro perché guardate che ha sporcato
un bellissimo slide niente votate chi
vince feriolo team mostarda
a quanto pare però vedere i nostri altri
video
scegliete quello che preferite ciao